so monads are a concept that was
invented in mathematics in the 1960s and
then it was rediscovered in computer
science in the 1990s and what it gives
you is a new way of thinking about
programming with effects and for me this
is one of the most important new ideas
and programming languages in the last 25
years so that's what we're going to be
looking at today programming with monads
we're going to come at this using a
simple example and the example that
we're going to look at is the idea of
writing a function that evaluates simple
expressions I'm going to use Haskell for
this but it doesn't matter if you don't
know anything about a scale because
we're going to use it in a very simple
way and I'm going to explain everything
as we're going along so what we want to
start with is by defining a simple
datatype for the kind of expressions
that we're going to be evaluating so
we'll use the data keyword in Haskell
which introduces a new data type and
then we're going to define a new data
type for expressions and then there's
two things that an expression can be it
can either be an integer value so we'll
write that down we have bow of an int or
it can be the division of two sub
expressions so we've got two
constructors here in our data type we've
got Val
which builds expressions from integers
I've got div which builds expressions
from two sub expressions so just to
reiterate what what's actually going on
here we're declaring a new data type
called expert and it's got two new
constructors one called vowel which
takes an integer parameter and one
called div which takes two sub
expressions as parameters as well so
basically what we're working with is
expressions that are built up from
integer values using a simple division
operator so many of you may not be
familiar of this kind of syntax let's
have a couple of examples of values of
this data type so that we make sure
everyone's on the same page so what I'm
going to do here is draw a little table
so on one side on the left hand side I'm
going to have what we would normally
write down in mathematics and then on
the right hand side we'll think how
would you translate this into a value in
this Haskell data type so let's have
three simple examples here we'll have
one
and we'll have six divided by two and
let's do one more example we'll have 6
divided by 3 divided by 1 so these are
simple expressions built up from
integers using a division operator we're
writing Haskell programs today so let's
think how do these things actually get
represented as values of our expression
data type so the first one is very
simple if we want to represent the value
1 we just need to use the Val tag so we
write vowel of 1 if we want to have an
expression like 6 divided by 2 well it's
a division so we have a div at the top
level and then we have two values we
have Val 6 and Val 2 and actually I'll
leave the last one is a little exercise
for you here so you can try this one for
yourself how do you represent this as a
value in Haskell well you're gonna need
two divisions you're going to need 3
vowel constructors and then a bunch of
brackets so this is the basic idea
we've got simple expressions built up
from integers using division and we want
to think about how do we write a program
to evaluate these expressions let's
write a program to do that so we're
going to write an evaluator and it's
going to be a program or a function in
this case that takes an expression as
input and what it's going to give back
is the integer value of that expression
and there's going to be two cases here
because we have two kinds of expressions
we have a case for values and we need to
figure out what to do with that which
we'll do in a moment and then we have a
case for division and we need to think
what to do with that so we've got the
skeleton here of a program and then we
just need to fill in the details so how
do you evaluate an integer value well
that's very simple you just give back
the number so if I had've a loved one as
far it's just 1 and then how do I
evaluate a division well these two
expressions here x and y this could be
as complicated as you wish so we need to
evaluate these recursively so what we
would do is evaluate the first one X and
that will give us an integer and then
we'll evaluate the second one Y and that
will give us another integer and then
all we need to do is divide one by the
other so this is a nice simple program
that evaluates these kind of expressions
built up from integers using division we
just have a simple recursive program two
cases
everything looks fine but there's a
problem with this program and the
problem is that it may crash because if
you divide a number by zero then that's
undefined so this program will just
crash so in particular if the value of
the expression Y here was zero then this
division operator would crash and you
get some kind of runtime error so we
don't want our programs to crash so we
think what do we do to fix this problem
first of all what we're going to do is
we're going to define a safe version of
the division operator which doesn't
crash anymore because that's basically
the root of the problem here division by
zero gives an undefined result and the
program is going to crash so let's
define a safe version of the division
operator we're going to define a
function called safe div and it's going
to take a couple of integers and it's
going to give back maybe an integer and
it maybe is the way that we deal with
things that can possibly fail in haskell
so the type here is not int to int to
int is int into maybe n't because
division may fail and we'll see how this
maybe type works in a moment so how do
we actually define safety we take two
integers and an M and then what we'll do
is check is the second of these zero
because that's the case when things
would go wrong so if M happen to be zero
then we will give back the result for
nothing okay so nothing is one of the
constructors in the maybe type if M is
not zero what we're going to do is just
give back the result of dividing so just
as another constructor in the maybe type
maybe only has two constructors nothing
which represents things that have gone
wrong or in our case division by zero
and just which represent things that
have gone fine in this case we actually
just get back the result of dividing one
number by the other so what we have here
now is a safe version of the division
operator which is explicitly checking
for the case when the program would have
crashed so this doesn't crash anymore it
returns one of two values either nothing
if things go wrong or just of the
division if things have gone fine so
what we can do then with this safe
division operator is rewrite our little
evaluator program to make sure that it
doesn't crash so our new evaluator is
going to have a slightly different type
than before so before there
you know program just took an expression
as input and then it gave back an
integer but that program could crash the
new evaluator takes an expression as
input as before but now it maybe gives
you an integer because it could fail it
could have division by zero so how do we
rewrite this evaluator so we'll do the
two cases again write down the skeleton
and then we'll fill in the details so in
the base case we can't just return n
this time because we've got to return a
maybe value and there's only two things
we could return either nothing or just
and in this case the right thing to do
is to return just event because if you
evaluate a value that's always going to
succeed so we use a successor tag which
is just and then we have the integer
value sitting in here if we have a
division now we need to do a bit more
work because when we evaluate X that may
fail when we evaluate Y that may fail
and then when we do the division that
may fail so we're going to need to do a
little bit of checking and management of
failure so what we're going to do is
when we evaluate a division first of all
we'll do a case analysis on the result
of evaluating X and that could be one of
two things it could either be nothing in
which case we're going to do something
or we could get just of some number in
so there's two cases to consider when we
evaluate the first parameter X either it
succeeds or it fails so in the failure
case if we get back nothing the only
sensible thing to do is just to say well
if evaluation of X fails the evaluation
of the whole division fails so we'll
just return nothing as well in the just
case then we need to evaluate the second
parameter Y so what we're going to do is
do another case analysis we'll do a case
eval of Y and then again there's two
possible outcomes which we could have
here either we could have nothing which
means it failed or we could have just of
M some other number in which case who
succeeded then again we need to think
what do we do in each of these two cases
so in the first case if the evaluation
of Y fails the only sensible thing to do
is say well we fail as well in the
second case we've now got to
successfully evaluated expressions X has
given the result n Y has given the
result M and now we can do the safe
division so in this case we just do safe
tip now we have a working evaluator
we started off with a two-line program
which kind of did the essence of
evaluation but it didn't check for
things going wrong it didn't check for a
division by zero
now we fix the problem completely we
have a program which works this program
will never crash it will always give a
well-defined result either nothing or
just but there's a bit of a problem with
this program and that it's it's a bit
too long it's a bit too verbose there's
quite a lot of noise in here I can
hardly see what's going on anymore
because it's all of this management of
failure so we can look at this program
and think how can we make this program
better and how can we make it more like
the original program that didn't work
but still maintain the fact that this
actually does the right thing and the
idea here is we're going to observe a
common pattern so when you look at this
program you can see quite clearly we're
doing the same thing twice we're doing
two case analyses what we're doing is
doing a case analysis on the result of
evaluating X and if it's nothing we give
back nothing and if it's just we do
something with the result and then we do
exactly the same thing with eval of Y
we're doing a case analysis on the
result of evaluating Y if that gives
nothing we give back nothing and a bits
adjust we do something with it
so a very common idea in computing is
when you see the same things multiple
times you abstract them out and have
them as a definition and that's what
we're going to do here so let's draw a
little picture first to capture the
pattern which we've seen twice so the
pattern we have here is we're doing a
case analysis on something so let me
just draw as a little box we don't know
what's in there we're doing a case
analysis on something and there's two
cases if it's nothing we give back
nothing and if we get just of some value
X then what we're going to do is we're
going to process it in some way we're
going to apply some other function to X
so this is the pattern which we've seen
twice in the first case we had eval of X
sitting here and in the second case we
had eval of Y sitting here but this is
the same pattern that we see two times
in the new valuator
which we've just written so what we can
do now is abstract this out as a
definition and the idea here is that
we're going to give names to these boxes
so this box is a maybe value it's gonna
be either nothing or a just so we'll
call it M and this box is going to be a
function
process the result in the case we're
successful so we'll call this F so we
can turn this picture here into a
definition now and then we can use it to
make our program simpler
so the definition we're going to have is
if we have some maybe value feeding into
or in sequence with some function f so
the the operator we're defining here is
this funny sequencing symbol welcome
back to that in a second what we're
going to do is a case analysis we're
going to look at what the maybe value is
if it's nothing
we'll give back nothing and if it's just
of X we'll apply the function to it okay
so we'll just captured the pattern which
we've seen twice by a definition now so
we have some maybe value then or in
sequence with some function f and all
we're going to do is look at what the
value of them maybe is if it's failed
will fail if it succeeds we pass the
result to the function f it's just the
idea of abstracting a common pattern as
a definition so now we can use this
definition to make our program simpler
so let's rewrite our evaluator once
again the type will remain the same
it takes in an expression as input and
it's going to give back and maybe value
as before what the definition is going
to be a bit simpler at this time so
let's write down the skeleton so if we
evaluate a value we're going to do
something if we evaluate a division
we're going to do something so what do
we write in the base case well I could
write just of n here but actually I'm
going to abstract that as well rather
than writing just an N I'm going to
write return of n so really what I'm
making is a little kind of side
definition that says return of X is the
same as just of X and then what are we
doing in the division case well we're
going to do an evaluation first we're
going to evaluate X and then if that's
successful using our little sequencing
operator we're going to feed the result
into a function so that function is
going to take the result and that comes
from evaluating that and then it's going
to evaluate Y so if we do eval of Y if
that's successful we're going to feed
that result into a function and here
again I'm using the lambda notation
which we did a video about previously
you can have a look back at that so if
these two things are both success
we'll have two values n and M and then
all we do is call safe depth with them
then close the brackets so this program
here is equivalent to the program which
we wrote which had all the nested case
analyses but that's all been abstracted
away now it's all been kind of
abstracted into return and the
sequencing and safe tip so this is a
nicer program now but still I'm not I'm
not entirely happy with this is still
some complexity in there that we're
still using the funny lambda notation
we're still using this funny symbol
which we've introduced maybe I can make
it even simpler so what language like
Haskell gives you is a special notation
for writing programs which have this
kind of form and this is called the do
notation so let me write this in do
notation and then we'll come back to
what this is all got to do with Mona's
so let's write this program in an even
more simple form and this will be our
final program we take an expression as
input and it's going to maybe deliver as
an integer and the base case will not
change so we'll get return of n but the
recursive case is going to become a bit
simpler because we use the do notation
as a shorthand for using the sequencing
operator which we've introduced so I can
say if I evaluate a division what I'm
going to do and this is the the keyword
which just gives you a shorthand for
exactly what we've just written is it's
not anything special it's just your hand
just syntactic sugar what we're going to
do is take the result n from the result
of evaluating X if it's successful then
we'll take the result M from the result
of evaluating Y if that's successful and
then we will call safe def and this is
our final program and I'm much happier
with this one I mean it looks kind of
similar to the original program a
similar level of complexity but all the
failure management is now handled for us
automatically
the failure is happening behind the
scenes with the do notation and it was
safe too but we don't need to see that
when we're reading this program this is
a much nicer program than the last one
because we've kind of abstracted away
from a lot of the detail so you can look
at a program like this and I've hardly
mentioned the word monads in the last
ten minutes you can say what's this
actually got to do with monads well what
we've actually done is we've
rediscovered what's
known as the maybe monad the maybe monad
is three things
it's the maybe type or really the maybe
type constructor because it takes a
parameter you can maybe omit an integer
or maybe of a boolean or maybe of
whatever you like and then it's two
functions and it's the function called
return and it's the sequencing operator
which we introduced and we can think
about what are the types of these things
so what return does is it takes a thing
of any old type a could be an integer
could be a billion could be whatever you
like and it converts it into a maybe
value so in our case this just took an
integer like five and we return just to
five okay so that's all the return was
doing it's basically just applying just
and what it gives you is a bridge
between the pure world of values here
and the impure world of things that
could go wrong so it's a bridge from
pure to impure if you like and what
sequencing does is it gives you a way of
sequencing things so you give it
something which can fail or maybe a and
then you give it a function that tells
you what to do with that a if you
succeed so an a to maybe B and then
finally what you're going to get back is
or maybe B okay and this is all that
Amanat is essentially a monad is some
kind of type constructor like maybe or
list or something else as many other
examples together with two functions
that have these types here so what we've
essentially done is rediscovered what's
called the maybe monad what's the point
of all of this I mean what's the point
we seem to have gone through quite a lot
of steps to to write in the end quite a
simple program what was the actual point
here so that there's four points which I
would like to emphasize here so the
first point is that the same idea we've
seen works for other effects as well
it's not specific to maybe which
captures failure the same idea captures
other kinds or you can use with other
kinds of effects like input/output like
mutable state like reading from
environments like writing to log files
non-determinism all sorts of other
things which you think of as being
effects in programming languages fit
exactly the same pattern so monads can I
give you a uniform framework for
thinking about programming with effects
another important point is that supports
pure
with effects I mean Haskell is a pure
language functions just take inputs and
produce outputs they don't have any kind
of side effects at all but you need to
have side effects the right real
programs so what one else give you is a
way of doing impure things like proper
side effects like input/output in a pure
programming language like Pascal another
important point here is that the use of
the effects is explicit in the types
when I wrote the evaluator which didn't
fail
it took an expression as input and it
delivered maybe of an integer so then
maybe in the tight is telling me that
this program may fail so this is the
idea of being explicit about what kind
of effects or side effects that your
programs can have in the types and this
is a very very powerful idea and the
last thing is it's a little bit strange
but it's particularly interesting it's
the idea of writing functions that work
for any effect might call this kind of
effect polymorphism so a simple example
of this would be maybe you have a
sequence of things which can have some
effects and you want to run them all one
after the other you could write a
generic function in a language like
Haskell which supports monads which
would take a sequence of effects of any
any kind any magnetic type and it would
run them for you so this is a very very
powerful idea and languages like Haskell
have libraries of kind of generic effect
functions which are very useful so
that's basically all I want to say just
come back to the start I think the idea
of programming with monads is one of the
most important developments in
programming languages in the last 25
years I find this particularly
fascinating we've only really touched on
the surface here and if you want to know
a little bit more I can do a bit of a
plug I have a new book which came out
fairly recently programming in Haskell
and this has got a chapter specifically
about this which goes into much more
detail only really touched on the
surface there's lots of things I didn't
say which maybe you need to know to
write real programs using this stuff so
you could have a look in the book to
find out more about that this is an
interesting point it causes quite quite
some problems for people learning
languages like Haskell because Haskell
people tend to use the proper
mathematical terms for things and those
terms are often quite foreign to
programmers and it does cause quite a
lot of difficulties so that some people
have the view that we shouldn't actually
have used the term monad where you
should have called them effects or
something like that so just use the more
kind of human or a familiar term but it
but it is an issue but I'm actually of
the point of view that if if we know the
proper term for something we should call
it that's something and the people who
are using it should just learn that term
I mean it's it's it's what it is it's am
honored we should kind of pay homage to
the mathematicians for discovering this
idea first and not kind of
reappropriation T the mathematicians
discovered this they should get credit
for that and so I'm quite happy with the
word monad but it does it it does cause
some problems when people are learning
programming languages because it does
sound a bit scary and there's lots more
scary terms like this in programming as
well this this is all built into into
languages like Haskell so there's
there's lots of libraries for
programming with magnetic things you
don't need to define a lot of the
infrastructure like maybe and return and
the sequencing for yourself there this
is kind of built in as libraries you can
define your own ones if you want to but
there's maybe kind of fifteen or twenty
one ads which are just lying around
waiting for people to use and if you
want to use multiple different one
answering your programs maybe need two
different kinds of effects maybe need
things that can fail and you need some
state there's ways of coping with that
kind of stuff as well so you don't need
to do all yourself it's mostly mostly
built in for you the uncertainty
principle tells us that we've got a
fundamental limit on how narrow we can
make that time because by narrowing down
that time we broaden out the energy
associated with the other with the
operation which sets a fundamental limit
because the narrow narrow narrow narrow
we get that the broad on broader and
broader the energy becomes so that's
it's a very fundamental limit when you
work it through and there's this grid